[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى ما وراء
الخبر رغم انتهاء عمليه عاصفه الحزم
والاعلان عن بدء عمليه اعاده الامل في
اليمن رغم ذلك اغار طائره التحالف على عدد
من مواقع الحوثيين والقوات المواليه
للرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح كما
اكدت المقاومه الشعبيه استمرارها في قتال
الحوثييين في مناطق عده نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في محورين اولا هل يمكن
اعتبار عمليه اعاده الامل في اليمن
استمرارا لعاصفه الحزم ولكن بادوات اخرى
ونهج
مختلف
كيف يمكن للاطراف اليمنيه الاستفاده من
بدء عمليه اعاده الامل للتوصل الى صيغه
تعيد الاستقرار الى اليمن وتتيح اعاده
بناء
[موسيقى]
الدوله انتهاء عمليه عاصفه الحزم وانطلاق
عمليه اعاده الامل في اليمن لم يكن يعني
وقف اطلاق النار وفق ما اكدت التطورات
الميدانيه على الارض فالمقاومة الشعبيه في
مدن يمنيه عده اكدت تصميمها على مواصله
قتال الحوثيين والقوات المواليه لصالح
وواصلت طائرات التحالف قصف اهداف منتقات
للحوثيين خاصه في تعز ولحج وكانت قياده
التحالف قد اشارت الى ان عمليه اعاده
الامل تشتمل على اجراءات عسكريه وسياسيه
ودبلوماسيه وقد دعى الحوثيون الى محادثات
بين الاطراف اليمنيه ترعاه الامم المتحده
بعد وقف القصف وفك ما دعوه الحصار على
الشعب
اليمني احتاج الامر الى نحو شهر من القصف
الجوي في اليمن حتى تحيد القدرات العسكريه
الهائله التي كانت بحوزه الحوثيين وحليفهم
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح واذ
تحقق ذلك وفق القائمين على عمليه عاصفه
الحزم فقد انطلقت فورا عمليه عاده الامل
التي يفترض ان تعني فيما تعنيه عوده الى
العمليه السياسيه دون تغول من هذا الفصيل
او استصغار لذلك الطرف واستعاده المسار
السياسي بهذه الروح كان الهدف الاساس منذ
بدء حمله القصف الجوي في السادس والعشر من
اذار مارس الماضي ايا كانت دوافع قرار وقف
عاصفه الحزم فان ما يتوقع ان تكون قد خلفت
الغارات من توازن للقوه بين الاطراف المتق
ل على الارض قد يقنعها
باستحالة مدرع الموالي للرئيس هادي
اشتباكات عنيفه عندما حاول مسلح الحوث
مسنودين بقوات الامن الخاصه المواليه
لصالح السيطره على مقر اللواء الا انهم لم
يتمكنوا من ذلك بفضل صمود منتسبيه ومعاده
المقاومه الشعبيه التي يبدو ان امامها
اعباء اضافيه الان على راسها القتال حتى
فرض السلم وتحقيق السلام في غضون ذلك شنت
طائرات تحالف عاصفه الحزم غارات جديده على
تجمعات الحوثيين وقوات صالح في عده مناطق
بمحافظتي تعز ولحج شماليه عدن مما يؤكد ان
الامر لا يتعلق بوقف اطلاق نار من النوع
المتعارف عليه في الصراعات وانما باليه
جديده لاداره الصراع يكون في بنك الاهداف
انتقائيا واجرائيا ويمكن القول ان مرحله
اعاده الامل هي اشبه بمرحله رقابه صارمه
على تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن الدولي حول
اليمن رقم
2216 الذي يشدد على الحل السياسي ويلزم
الحوثيين ومن والاهم بالعوده الى اوضاع ما
قبل الحادي من سبتمبر ايلول الماضي تاريخ
سيطرته بالقوه على العاصمه صنعاء
واستيلائهم على مرافق الدوله ومؤسساتها
ونهب اسلحه الجيش والهيمنه على وسائل
الاعلام وغيرها من الاجراءات التي جعلت من
تحركهم ذاك انقلابا مكتمل
الاركان موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع
ضيوفنا من الرياض الاستاذ ابراهيم المرعي
الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه والاستراتيجيه و
ينضم الينا من لندن الكاتب والباحث
السياسي اليمني محمد جميح وعبر الهاتف من
صنعاء الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد الوهاب
الشرفي نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا ابدا معك من
الرياضه الاستاذ ابراهيم المرعي طبعا
الجميع توقع توقع انه يعني بعد انتهاء
عاصفه الحزم وتدمير القدرات العسكريه
للميليشيات الحوثيه كما اعلن
امس انه يعني المرحله المقبله ستكون اكثر
هدوء اليوم ما زال هناك قص مستمر ولم تقوض
حتى قدره الحوثيين طالما انهم يعني فعلوا
ما فعلوه في تعز اليوم كما
تعلم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك اختي
خديجه واحيي مشاهدي قناه الجزيره واحيي
ضيوفك الكرام يا
سيدهي ال العمليات او عمليه عاصفه الحزم
قوضت ودمرت 98% من قدره الصاروخيه لصالح
والحوثي اكثر من 80% من مخازن
الذخيره دمرت معظم معداتهم الثقيله اها
فيما يخص
ا ما فعلوه في تعز اها انا اود ان اشير
الى ما حدث في تعز تعز عند كان اللواء
35 منتشرا في تعز ولم يكن موجود في
المعسكر واستغل ا واستغل الحوثيين فراغ
المعسكر مع وجود
بعض الجنود والضباط وهم قليل وقاموا
باحتلال المعسكر ولكن اللواء 35 كضباط
وجنود ما زالوا موجودين وما زالوا في تعز
وما زالوا يقاومون الحوثيين في شوارع
تعز اهم ما حصل منذ البارح منذ توقف عمليه
عاصفه الحزم ساعه
24 هو ان التحالف قام بتوجيه ضربات جويه
استذ ابرايم المرعي اعتذر اعتذر منك
لننتقل مباشره الان الى واشنطن لننقل لكم
جانبا من المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يعقده الان
السفير السعودي لدى الولايات المتحده عادل
جوبير حول وقف عمليه عاصفه الحزم واطلاق
عمليه اعاده الامل لنذهب الى
واشنطن
للتخلص من الاسلحه البالستيه والطائرات
وال التي كانت تحت حوزه قوات الحوثيين ومن
مع عبد الله صالح وكما ان قواتنا الجويه
والتحالف استطاعت ازاله هذا الخطر
وبالتالي عندما حققنا ذلك ونحن الان ايضا
نقوم بعمليه حمايه الحكومه الشرعيه لليمن
وحمايه الشعب اليمني ل لا نسمح لل
المجموعات المعاديه بتايد من ايران وحزب
الله اذاء الشعب اليمني ونود ان تمهد
الطريق لحل سلمي فنحن قلنا لطالما قلنا
انه ليس هناك حل عسكري للنزاع في يمن
والحل يجب ان
يكون سلميا بناء على قرار مجلس الامر 22
16 ومبادر دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
والعمل في اليمن وطالما عبرنا عن الامل
بان الحوثين سيرون
حكمه المشاركه في العمليه السياسيه بدل من
محاوله الس السيطره على البلاد بالقوه
ونحن وضحنا لهم بان لن نسمعهم بالسيطره
على اليمن بالقوه
و وك نتيجه للتخلص من كل مصادر الخطر على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اسلحه التي
كانت يمتلكها الحوثيون او سيطروا عليها و
سلبوها من الق اليه اليمنيه انتقلنا الى
انهاء عمليه عاصفه الحزم الى عمليه ما
سميناه اعاده الامل والهدف فيها هو
التركيز على العمليه السياسيه والعمليه
الانسانيه مع محاوله والسعي نحو حمايه
اليمنيين من اي اعتداء حوثي وحمايه
ومواجهه اي حركه عدوانيه يقومون بها
الحوثيون او يحاولون القيام بها في اليمن
وقد اليوم الواقع بدانا في منطقه تعز ذلك
ان الحوثيين كانوا قد قصفوا مواقع
الفرقه 35 من اعلى الجبال فتدخل عسكريا
لانهاء ذلك واننا شهدنا حركات من قبل
الحوثيين تدعو الى الازعاج في منطقه عدن
وحيث حصلت بعض الاشتباكات وشاهدنا حركات
تحركات للقوات الحوثيه من ثلاثه اتجاهات
نحو عيد من ال طالع من البيضا ومن الحج
ونتوقع انهم
سيدخلون عدن خلال ساعات ان لم يكن قبل ذلك
ولذلك نحن عازمون على استجابه لطلب الشرعي
من الحكومه اليمنيه لتقديم المساعده لهم
لمنع حصول ذلك على الحوثيين ان لا يتوهم
اطلاقا
باننا لن سنتوقف عن استخدام القوه لمنعهم
من الاستيلاء والسيطره على اليمن عن طريق
العدوان وبتالي هذا الموقف لن يتغير واننا
مستعدون المساهمه في العمليه السياسيه وقد
ظهرت بعض التصريحات من الحوثيين من قياده
الحوثيين بقبولهم بالعمليه السياسيه
ومشاركتهم في العمليه السياسيه ولكن بعد
ساعات من ذلك شاهدنا تحركات لقواتهم
وشاهدنا بانه يستخدمون السلاح ضد قوات
الحكومه اليمنيه الشرعيه وبالتالي هذا ليس
بموقف او سلوك مجموعه تسعى الى
حل حل خلافاتها مع مع بقيه اليمنيين عن
طريق الحوار والسلام وكما اننا كنا مصممون
وعازمون على تقليل وتدمير القوات قوه
القوه التي تشكل خطرا على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في عمليه عاصفه الحزم فنحن ايضا
عازمون على حمايه الشعب اليمني ومواجهه اي
تحركات عدوانيه قد يقوم بها الحوثيون
اثناء عمليه اعاده الامل وبالتالي وبعد ان
وضحت ذلك ساتوقف لاتلقى بعض الاسئله كما
اود ان نضيف شيئا واحدا وهو ان اهداف
عمليه اعاده الامل هي حمايه اليم المدنيين
اذا اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا واياكم جزءا من
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده السفير السعودي
عادل جبير في واشنطن حول وقف عمليه عاصفه
الحزم واطلاق عمليه اعاده الامل قبل ان
انتقل الى محمد جميح فقط اعود لنستكمل
الفكره بناء ايضا على ما قاله الان السفير
السعودي استاذ
ابراهيم المرعي واضح ان ما ما يفهم من
كلام السفير السعودي ان العمليه انتقلت
الان من المبادره والفعل الى رد الفعل الى
الدفاع حيث يوجد حوثيون حيث يوجد عمليات
للحوثيين هناك رد فعل قوي هل هكذا فهمت
كلام السفير
السعودي يا سيدتي ساعق على كلام السفير
ولكن النقطه المهمه جدا انه بعد توقف
العمليات ساعه 24 بالامس راينا ضربات جويه
وجهت الى تعز ووجهت الى فندق الرحاب في
عدن ا وهذه اشاره واضحه وصريحه سواء لمن
يتابع العمليات او للحوثي وصالح بان قوات
التحالف لن تتوقف عن حمايه المدنيين
والمواطن اليمني ولن تسمح باي تحركات
عمليات ل الميليشيات الحوثيه هذا صريح
واضح وانا كنت مطمئن جدا عندما نفذت هذه
الضربات الجويه في اليوم الاول منذ وقوف
العمليات لكي لا يفسر ان التحالف توقف عن
دعم اهلنا في اليمن او عن حمايتهم نعم هو
لم يتوقف ولكن يبدو ان العبء الاكبر
والسؤال للاستاذ محمد جميح العبء الاكبر
سيكون الان على المقاومه الشعبيه على
الارض قبل قليل السفير السعودي عادل جبير
قال نتوقع انه بعد يعني خلال الساعات
القادمه انه يكون في تقدم نحو عدن قال
بالحرف نتوقع دخولهم عدن خلال ساعات واننا
كما قال سنمنع حدوث ذلك الان المقاومه
الشعبيه ماذا بامكانها ماذا بمقدورها ان
تفعل ااء هذا
التطور طبعا انا في تصوري ان المرحلتين
هما وجهان لمرحله واحده لو تصورنا ان
الحرب الجويه على الحوثيين وقوات صالح
تتكون من مرحلتين فان المرحله الاولى
عاصفه الحزم قد يمكن ان تسمى مرحله نهايه
العمليات الكبرى في هذه الحرب بينما
المرحله الاخرى اعاده الامل هي تظل
للعمليات الصغرى من المتابعه
وال الضربات النوعيه والاشراف التام على
التزام الحوثيين بالاتفاق الذي يمكن ان
يكون قد ابرم ولم يعلن بعد لكن بالنسبه
للمقاومه المقاومه في عدن الحوثيون اليوم
في وضع صعب يتفاوضون على خروجهم من مطار
عدن من اجل سلامه انفسهم لكنهم يريدون
الخروج باسلحتهم والمقاومه ترفض ذلك هناك
بعض الجيوب للحوثيين
في في خورمكسر وعدن بمجملها اصبحت الى حد
كبير محرره بيد المقاومه الشعبيه العدنيه
الجنوبيه اليمنيه
البطله الحوثيون ادركوا فيما يبدو ان عدن
قد خرجت من ايديهم وربما ان الرساله التي
فهموها كانت خاطئه عندما اعلن عن نهايه
عمليات عاصفه الحزم فهموا ان ذلك هو وقف
لاطلاق النار وهذا ما دعا بهم او ما حدى
بهم الى الاعتداء على مقر اللواء ال 35 في
تعز وتحريك قواتهم الى عدن لكنهم بالفعل
سيواجهون باستمرار العمليات نفسها لانه
حتى العميد عسيري بالامس صرح
بان العمليات ستستمر اذا حرك الحوثيون
قواتهم باتجاه مناطق اخرى
واذا تعرض المدنيون للخطر المدنيون معرضون
للخطر في تعز وفي عدن وفي مارب وفي اكثر
من منطقه ملتهبه والحوثيون يحركون قواتهم
الاشكال في تصوري ان الحوثيين يتعاملون مع
عاصفه الحزم وكانهم يتعاملون مع الاطراف
الداخليه بامكانهم ان يتملص مما التزموا
به او بامكانهم ان يخدر عبر عنها س سعود
عندما قال انهم انهم قبلوا ب دخول يعني
مرحله الحوار السياسي ثم تراجعوا بعد
ذلك اليوم
بدخولهم هجومهم على لواء 35 في في تعز
اتحول بالسؤال الى الاستاذ عبد الوهاب
الشرفي الان واضح ان ما هو معروض على
الحوثيين هو حوار سياسي على اساس المبادره
ان يقبلوا بمبادره الخليجيه وان يقبلوا
بالقرار الاممي رقم 200
2216 ما الذي يمنعهم من استغلال هذه
الفرصه السانحه الان للقبول بهذا الامر
ودخول مرحله جديده من الحوار السياسي يكون
لهم مق قعد مثل كل باقي مكونات الطيف
السياسي اليمني الى طاوله حوار تنصف
الجميع بدايه مساء الخير لك وساده
المشاهدين الكرام ولضيوفك
الاكارم الحقيقه ربما الحديث
عن العوده الى العمليه السياسيه هو حديث
يتم على لسان الجميع ليس هناك طرف لا
داخلي ولا طرف خارجي بمن فيهم انصار الله
ايضا الا ويتحدث عن الاستعداد للعوده عن
طاوله العوده الى طاوله المفاوضات لكن
المشكله تكمن في ما ينظر اليه الان على
انه تدخل خارجي في القضيه وهو ما عرف
بعمليه عاصفه الحزم كان هذا الامر مطلوب
اولا توقفه قبل العوده لاي مفاوضات طبعا
في الاخير المطالبه
بالالتزام قرار مجلس الامن هي القضيه هي
تتمحور حول الاعتراف بشرعيه دي على اعتبار
انه المفاوضات قد كانت وصلت الى هذه
النقطه عندما كانت التفاوضات جاريه بين
المكونات اليمنيه قبل عاصفه الحزم وربما
ان ما اعلن عنه الان من انهاء عاص نعم
ولكن كل هذا كل ما قلته يعني استاذ شرفي
الدليل على حاله من التخبط في الموقف
الحوثي القبول ثم
التراجع يعني صدور شروط جديده في كل مره
هذا دليل على انهم طرف لا يمكن لبقيه
الاطراف ان تثق في الطرف الحوثي انا اتكلم
الان عن هذه اللحظه انت لو اطلعت الان على
البيان او الذي جاء على لسان محمد عبد
السلام الناطق باسم انصار الله هو ربما
لازال يراوح في نفس المكان نفس الموقف
الذي هو يعني جسده قبل البدء بعاصفه الحزم
هو ذاته سنسال اذا سنسال بعد الفاصل عن
كيفيه او كيف يمكن للاطراف اليمنيه
الاستفاده من بد عمليه اعاده الامل التي
بدات اليوم للتوصل الى صيغه تعيد
الاستقرار الى اليمن وتتيح اعاده بناء
الدوله اليمنيه من جديد فنرجو انلا تذهبوا
بعيدا ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناق قش بعد انطلاق عمليه اعاده
الامل في اليمن وكيف يمكن البناء عليها
لاعاده بناء الدوله اليمنيه وتحقيق
الاستقرار فيها استاذ ابراهيم المرعي
برايك كيف يمكن للاطراف اليمنيه الاستفاده
من عمليه اعاده الامل الجاريه الان ل
الوصول الى صيغه تعيد الاستقرار الى اليمن
من
جديد افضل طريقه هو الاذعان لقرار مجلس
الامن بقي 48 ساعه
بقي بعد غد سيكون انتهت المهله العش ايام
الان في عمليه عاصفه الحزم كان هناك عشر
دول مشاركه في التحالف بعد يومين سيكون
هناك امام مجلس الامن اما ان يذعن الحوثي
وصالح لقرار مجلس الامن او ان يصدر قرارا
اخر وهناك امكانيه لصدور قرار تحت فصل
السابع البند 41 و42 ال 42 يتيح تشكيل
تحالف وليس من عشر دول وانما تحالف دولي
لتطبيق وتنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن فلذلك
واضح تماما انه ليس امامهم سوى القبول
والاذعان سواء اليوم او غدا او بعد غد
هناك هناك المجتمع الدولي يقف في خندق
واحد لاعاده الشرعيه ولسح قوات الحوثي
ولخروج من جميع محافظات اليمن ولك سيتم
وانا والمجتمع الدولي يقول ذلك لست انا من
يقول ذلك ولذلك انقول لاهلنا في اليمن حتى
وان رايتم تحركات عسكريه حوثيه اليوم او
غدا فهذا لن يستمر سينسحب الحوثي من جميع
المحافظات وسيخلق العاصمه صنعاء وسيعود
الرئيس هادي والحكومه اليمنيه
كحكومة عاصفه الحزم وهذا سبب صدور القرار
22 16 ولذلك عندما تحقق طيب استاذ محمد
جميح لانه باقي معنا فقط دقائق ما مدى
قدره اسالك نفس السؤال
قدره
المكونات القوى السياسيه اليمنيه بمجملها
كيف يمكن لها ان تستفيد من عمليه اعاده
الامن الامل عفوا لتبني نهجا جديدا تستدرك
فيه ما
فات
انا اعتقد انها فرصه وان الكره في مرمى
الحوثيين بالذات فيما يخص هذه المساله
هناك ايضا يعني بعض المعلومات ان
الحوثييين قبلوا بقرار مجلس الامن وتنفيذه
ولكنهم طلبوا مهله ثلاثه ايام بدات باليوم
وا تنتهي بنهايه المهله الممنوحه لهم
نهايه العشره ايام تنتهي بالجمعه ا ف وذلك
بعد مفاوضات ربما
شبه مطوله بين ممثلين عن الحكومه اليمنيه
وايضا الدكتور القربي في القاهره وايضا
السفير الايراني هناك طبخه طبخت من اجل
انضاج قبول حوثيين لكامل قرار مجلس الامن
الدولي بدون اي مراوغه والحوثيون يبدو
انهم قبلوا والمساله الفاصله بيننا وبين
ان نتحقق من هذه المعلومات هي يومان فقط
الغد وبعد الغد ا لكن اكثر المعلومات تشير
الى الى القبول و ما توقف عاصفه الحزم
وانتقالها الى اعاده الامل الا بعد ان جرت
عده اتصالات بين عواصم اقليميه وعواصم
عالميه دخل فيها متعهدون
دوليون ملزمون بان يوافق الحوثيون وبان
وضمنا لتنفيذ الحوثيين لتعهدات بسحب
ميليشياتهم بتسليم الاسلحه التي لا تزال
متبقيه لديهم بالانسحاب من دوائر الدوله
والانسحاب من العاصمه ومن كافه المدن
اليمن ت احتلوها هذا شيء يعني ينبغي ان
يفهمه الناس جميعا والحوثيون الان يريدون
فقط كسب الوقت وخداع جماهيرهم وخداع
قواعدهم التي تقاتل اليوم منعزله في جزر
منعزله عن القياده التي قصفت والتي قطعت
خطوط امدادات وتلاها مع القواعد الاخرى
وبالتالي هل تتوقع ان يقبل الحوثيون بذلك
الحوثيين هم اعلنوا موقفهم انهم لن
يتعاطوا مع اي شيء ما لم تتوقف العمليات
العسكريه تماما وبالنسبه لي انا وجهه نظري
ان التحول من عاصفه الحزم الى عمليه الامل
هي نوع من
المراوغه تسبق الاجتماع المجلس الامن في
محاوله الانتزاع قرار يكون اكثر قسوه ضد
ضد انصار الله وضد صالح بدليل الكلام الذي
تحدث عنه الرئيس هادي بدلا من ان يشجع
مثلا عندما تحدث صالح وقال انه سيتعاطى
ايجابيا مع قرار مجلس الامن بدلا من ان
يشجع هذا الامر هو حاول ان يكسر هذا الامر
تماما وشكك فيه بقدر كبير مما يعني ان
المراد الان هو تصوير ان انصار الله
متمردين مبدئيا وقد هيئت لهم الظروف وتم
تخفيف العمل العسكري بناء على طلب الامين
العام للامم المتحده الذي قال يجب ان يتم
الاسراع في انهاء هذه العمليه وبالتالي هم
يهيئون الان لمحاوله انتزاع قرار يكون
اكثر قسوه هذا هو كل ما في الامر بينما
التوجه للحل السياسي لم ليس صادقا حتى
الان من قبل الخارج ابتداء بمعنى طيب شكرا
هذا ما سمح به وقت ال البرنامج شكرا لك
عبد الوهاب الشرفي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اليمني كنت معنا من صنعاء ونشكر ايضا
الاستاذ ابراهيم المرعي الخبير في الشؤون
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه ومن لندن الكاتب
والباحث السياسي اليمني محمد جميح هذا
ناتي الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اطيب
المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء